foreign
I think the hard problem of
Consciousness is not a problem to be
solved I think it's an internal
contradiction of the physicalist way of
thinking because you know the world we
have the world we inhabit is a world of
qualities colors flavors melodies and
traditional or historically
scientists began using quantities or
numbers to describe that work but at
some point we replaced the thing
described with the description we said
Manta is what really exists and matter
is exhaustively described with a list of
numbers
and the qualities they are somehow uh
created or generated by the brain inside
our skulls well Bernardo describe signs
I think he's not describing actual sites
I think he's describing a philosopher
um oversimplification of a particular
moment of Science in 18th century in
which the idea of science was very very
little balls pulling and pushing one
another and it's sort of hard to think
like little storms pulling and pushing
one another make something like our
subjective experience that's not that's
that's not what scientists life is much
more rich and the conceptual tools of
science are not just numbers
and Revelation between numbers are
qualitative
we describe qualitative reality with
science not just how many things there
are or or that the numbers are tools for
describing what is going on so I agree
that the relation between ourselves and
the world has to be not a relation of uh
the world is he that it but it's a
relation like me and you I am part of
the world I relate to the world as a
part of it and Carl in the case of Carlo
he defends the notion that all physical
entities are relational like movement
movement is relational but of course for
movements to exist there has to be that
which moves something needs to move in
relation to something else and these two
things cannot be movement for us to
speak of movement it avoids the
implication of his own Theory by going
into the fallacy of infinite regress by
saying that its relations all the way
down this is how how the current
Paradigm tries to survive today through
a combination of hand waving empirical
negligence and appeals to fallacies 10
years 20 years ago 30 years ago many
people were under the impression that in
order to understand life something
absolutely
is needed because life is radically
different it's obviously radically
different than non-life there is a gap
between the two so you need an alarm for
a vitalist force to explain it and
nobody thinks about that not because we
have understood what is life because
life is just a complex phenomenon a lot
of things is happening a lot of terminal
Dynamics a lot of biochemistry a lot of
complexity a lot of interrelations
between things so with a better
understanding it just lost all its uh
not his interest it's super interesting
and of course many things we don't
understand yet but we see how it's just
a part of the natural world which we can
account it was a general level way of
understanding things which science as
this is not a
science being too potential potential so
explain everything it's the other way
around I think it's those who say look
it's impossible that science could
explain that that pretend to have a a a
a a a a
certainty about rational thinking that
shows that something is impossible
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas a IAI TV